well I think of this instance it does
have and actually one of the things I
constantly say is that because this is
an issue in certain parts of Palestine
known and not in others is that you know
you can't but you can't have everyone
arguing for a two-state solution if
whoops this is a place that doesn't
exist so no I think that that is a very
important thing to have happen ow the
purpose of the religious leadership in a
way is to be taking away from people i
think or more really removing the
argument that somehow your religion
impels you to say that the state of
israel can't exist and what is important
is to realize that actually as I say
what you've got in this bit of land is
two peoples living there and the idea of
a two-state solution in which there is a
state of Israel and the state of
Palestine is precisely to make sense of
that that's how you that's how you
reconcile you reconcile on the basis
that the Israelis have a state which is
secure and the Palestinians have the
dignity and justice of their own state
it's the only way to do it and actually
religious people can take away remove
from both sides the objection to that
concept